دعواتنا لمظاهرات عامه في ايران اليوم
والمحتشون يؤكدون الاستمرار في التظاهر
حتى اسقاط النظام
تطالب اوكرانيا سرا بان تظهر لروسيا
انفتاحها على المحادثات
مفوض الامم المتحده السامي لحقوق الانسان
يحث ملكه وتر العماسك الاحترام حقوق
الانسان
[موسيقى]
احييكم اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره الاخباريه
من العربيه صباح الخير
الى تنظيم احتياجات اليوم الاحد الساعه
الخامسه مساءا في جميع انحاء ايران وقالت
هذه المجموعات انها لن تتوقف حتى النصر
الكامل مؤكده انها ستبقى في الشوارع حتى
اسقاط النظام الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
اخبار
[موسيقى]
رؤساء السلطات التشريعيه والتنفيذيه
والقضائيه بالاسراء في النظر بملفات
العناصر التي وصفوها بانها مثيره للشغل
والفوضى واكد الرئيس ابراهيم الرئيسي
ورئيس البرلماني والسلطه القضائيه ضروره
التصدي لما وصفوه بمؤامرات التفرقه في
البلاد
امواج الاحتجاجات الايرانيه تتجاوز حاجز
الخوف منذ عام
1999 وصولا للعام الحالي ست موجات
احتجاجيه وبين كل موجه واخرى يتشكلوا
وعيون وادراك لما يطمح اليه الايرانيون ام
النظام ستبقى الياته واحده في مواجهه
تطلعات الشعب الايراني ومطالبه الاخذ في
التغيير والتطور
[تصفيق]
مشهد الاحتجاجات هذه المره يختلف كليا عن
ما كانت عليه سابقا احتجاجات تمتلك رمزا
لتفعوله الايرانيون وعلى نقيض الاحتجاجات
السابقه المهدده بتراجع الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه يطالب المحتجون
بالحق في الحياه والحريه بعد مقتل مهس
امني على يد شرطه الاخلاق
[موسيقى]
ومن اختلاف لاخر بظهور الانتفاضه الشعبيه
الايرانيه معبره عن الاقليات وعبره الحدود
الارقيات وخلافاتها
الاكراد والاحوازيين والبنوش في المحافظات
الحدوديه ينتفضون وامام البلوش في ايران
يؤيده تافات المحتجين المطالبه بتغيير
جذريه
الشعب الذي يتظاهر منذ 50 يوما في الشوارع
لن تستطيع ارغامه على التراجع عبر القتل
والاعتقالات ادعوا الى استفتاء عاما
برعايه اماميه
[موسيقى]
الانتفاضه الايرانيه تاتي في ظل مستقبل
سياسيا ضبابي للنظام خلافه غير واضحه
للمرشد الاعلى علي خامنئي في ظل تقارير
تشير الى تراجع الصحيح
وغياب للتيارات المعتدله ما دفع الرئيس
البرلماني الايراني
للخروج عن صمته
لابد من الاعتراف بان الاحتجاجات لها جذور
سياسيه عميقه وليست مجرد نتيجه لحراك
امريكي او اسرائيلي
[تصفيق]
كلما زادت حده الاحتجاجات زادت معها
الفجوه بين النظام والمتظاهرين بمختلف
اطيافهم طلاب الجامعات والمدارس شباب
وفتيات ينضم اليهم شخصيات فنيه وثقافيه
ايرانيه تواجه حمله اعتقالات واسعه
لتلقى الانتفاضه تضامنا دوليا طالما طالبت
باستعادته هويه البلاد على السمان العربيه
قدمت المانيا لائحه جديده تقترح على
الاتحاد الاوروبي اضافتها لتوسيع العقوبات
على ايران بحسب موقع ديرشبيل الالماني
وتضم اللائحه التي عملت عليها المانيا الى
جانب ثمان دول اوروبيه اخرى واحدا و 30
فردا وكيانا ايرانيا بسبب قمع الاحتياجات
وبحسب الموقع فان اللائحه تضم مؤسسه من
القطاع الامني مسؤوله عن اعمال القمع فيما
يبحث وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي لائحه
العقوبات الجديده على ايران خلال اجتماعهم
المقبل في الرابعه عشر من نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
نتائج
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
اختبار ايران للصاروخ ان مثل هذه الاعمال
ليست ذات جدوى وتعمل على زعزعه الاستقرار
وعربه برايس عن قلقي واشنطن من تطويري
ايران المستمر للصواريخ والذي يمثل قلقا
كبيرا بشان الاسلحه
من جهتي هي اكد مبعوث الولايات المتحده
الخاص بايران روبرت مالي ان تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه ايران عن ارسال عدد محدود من
المسيارات لروسيا غير صحيحه مشيرا الى ان
طهران تساعد عبر مسيراتها باستهداف
المدنيين في اوكرانيا كما اوضح مالي انا
سهران لديها ايضا عسكريون في مناطق خاضعه
لسيطره روسيا في اوكرانيا
في كل مره ومناسبه انكر النظام الايراني
تزويده روسيا بالاسلحه والمسيرات التي
تستعملها لقصف البنى التحتيه ومنشات
الطاقه الاوكرانيه
فكل التقارير وتحقيقات كاذبه وبلا اساس من
الصحه كانت تقول طهران ايران كررت نفي
قيامها بتزويد روسيا بطائره مسيره
لاستخدامها في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا قبل ان
تعود لتقر بذلك
الجزء الثاني
المزاعم التي لا اسس لها من الصحه و بانها
نقلت مسيرات لاستخدامها في الصراع في
اوكرانيا من المخيم للامال ان تحاول هذه
الدول اطلاقا حمله تضليل ضد ايران خدمه
لجندتها السياسيه
ايران لم ولن تقدم اي سلاح لاستخدامه في
حرب اوكرانيا
اتفقنا مع وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه على
ان يقدموا لنا اي دليل لديهم حول استخدام
روسيا لطائرات بدون طيار ايرانيه في
اوكرانيا
وكانت الضغوط الدوليه المتناميه استمرت
متهمه طهران بارسال المسيره الى ساحه
القتال في اوكرانيا
الدليل على استخدام المسيارات التي باعتها
طهران الى روسيا ضد المدنيين الاوكرانيين
واضح مثل الشمس
حكايه المسيره الايرانيه في اوكرانيا عرت
كذب نظام ايران وجعلته في مرمى عقوبات
دوليه جديده بسبب تدخلها في الصراع
باوكرانيا الى جانب عقوبات سابقه بسبب
افعالها فيما يخص زعزعه امن واستقرار دول
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وقمع الاحتجاجات وخرق
حقوق الانسان بالاضافه الى البرنامج
النووي بلال الوجداني العربيه
كشفت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن اداره
اوكرانيا على التعبير عن انفتاحهم على
التفاوض مع روسيا والتخلي عن رفضهم العلني
للمشاركه في محادثات سلام قبل ازاحه
الرئيس الذي بوتين عن السلطان ونقلات
الصحيفه عن اشخاص لم تسمهم على درايه
بالمناقشات قولهم ان الطلب المسؤولين
الامريكيين لا يهدف الى الضغط على
اوكرانيا للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات من
هو محاوله محسوبه لضمان ان تحافظ كاف على
دعم دول اخرى تخشى من تاجيش الحرب لسنوات
قادمه
بعث مفاوض الامم المتحده اسامي لحقوق
الانسان كبير رساله مفتوحه الى الى ماسك
الملك الجديد لشركه تويتر يحثه فيها على
ضمان ان تكون حقوق الانسان شيئا اساسيا
بالنسبه لاداره تويتر وقال المفوض السامي
في الرساله ان تويتر جزء من ثوره عالميه
غير طريقه تواصلنا لكنه اضاف بانه يكتب
بقلق وخوف عن المجال الرقمي العام ودوره
تويتر فيه مشيرا الى ان تويتر مثل كل
الشركات بحاجه الى فهم الاضرار المرتبطه
بمن قصتها
لمعالجتها وقالت ترك يجب على ماسك ان يضع
حواجز الحمايه امام استخدام منصه وتطورها
هذا واطلق تطبيق تويتر اشتراكا مقابل 8
دولارات شهريا للحصول على العلامه الزرقاء
للحسابات التي تم التحقق منها في اطار
اصلاح نظام التحقق الخاص بالمنصه التي
يقودها الملك الجديد الى ماسك واعلن تويتر
ان المستخدمين الذين يشتركون الان يمكنهم
الحصول على علامات التحقق الزرقاء بجوار
اسمائهم تماما مثل المشاهير والشركات
والسياسيين ياتي ذلك بعد يوم من بدا تسريح
العاملين في الشركه لخفض التكاليف والذي
طالب وصفه موظفي الشركه
مين هو اليها نصف موظفين تويتر خرجوا من
الشركه بعد ان خسروا وظائفم بقرار من
المالك الجديد للشركه واليها عادوا للحديث
عن ما جرى له
هاشتاج وانتم وضعهم موظفون تويتر السابقون
بعد ان وجدوا انفسهم خارج تويتر الشركه في
الهاشتاج غرد كبار وموظفين وصغارهم عن
غضبهم اذا قرار ماسك وعن تجربتهم
وذكرياتهم مع تويتر مقدمين لبعضهم البعض
رسائل الدعم فيما ذهب اخرون نحو رفع قضيه
على ماسك حتى ان بعضهم اشتكى انه طرد من
قسمه وفريق حقوق الانسان بالشركه
عمليه تسريح الموظفين الجماعيه لم تكن
بالخطوه المفاجئه فالاحداث منذ وصول
المالك الجديد الى الشركه متسارعه وغير
متوقعه عدا ان عمليه التسريح ليست جديده
في تاريخ ماسك الاداري ففي تسلا قصه شبيهه
شركه تويتر التزمت الصمت بشان حجم
التسريحات رئيس اداره السلامه والنزاهه في
الشركه قال ان 15 من موظفي تويتر في فريق
السلامه والنزاهه المسؤول عن منع انتشار
المعلومات الخاطئه والمحتوى الضار ثم
تسريحه
في حين تحدثت وسائل اعلام الاجنبيه بانها
طلبت تصريحا رسميا عن حالات الطرد في
تويتر من مدير التواصل في الشركه لتفاجا
بانه هو ايضا مطرود
الى الماسك الذي لم يتوقف عن التغريد
بغزاره منذ استحواثه على المنصه برر قرار
التسريح بانه لا يوجد خيار عندما تخسر
الشركه اكثر من اربعه ملايين دولار في
اليوم موضحا في تغريده انه تم منح كل من
خرج من الخدمه ثلاثه اشهر تعويضه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد على بعد ايامنا من
الانتخابات النصفيه صعد الرئيس الامريكي
ضد شركات النفط الامريكيه مهددا اياها
بزياده الضرائب لدفعها الى خفض الاسعار
فيما حذرت شركه كبيره من هذا التصعيد
ازمه في الولايات المتحده ويجعلها على
صحيح ساخن قبيل ايام من اجراء الانتخابات
النصفيه الرئيس الامريكي يصعد ضد شركه
النفط الامريكيه وهددها بزياده الضرائب
لدفعها الى خفض الاسعار متهما اياها بخفض
الانتاج ايضا استخدم التهديد نفسه في
بدايه تسليمه الرئاسه لكنه كان يضغط على
الشركه ذاتها لوقف وخفض الانتاج لمراعات
البيئه
النفط الامريكيه رفضت زياده الانتاج
للحفاظ على ارباحها وان بيضا محبط مشيره
الى توقيت تصعيد الرئيس الامريكي قبل
الانتخابات النصفيه
الطاقه الامريكيه من بينها شيفرون واكسون
حذروا من خطوره فرد ضرائب غير متوقعه
محتمله
خطاب بايد ان كان واحدا من مجموعه ضربات
زرعت عدم الثقه واذكت التوتر مع قطاع
صناعه الوقود الاحفوري في امريكا في عهد
الاداره الحاليه وفقا لمقابلات مع
المديرين التنفيذيين وغيرهم من العاملين
في مجال النفط والغاز حسب وكاله بلومبيرج
مخزونات الوقود وصلت الى مستويات منخفضه
لدرجه مقلقه نهايه اكتوبر الماضي الامر
الذي تسبب بحدوث حاله استنفار في البلاد
بلال البوجداني العربيه
ارتفاع وسائل الوقود في امريكا قد يتسبب
بالاطاحه بديمقراطيين من الكونجرس حيث اكد
استطلاع لاي بي سي نيوز انه توجد علاقه
بين اسعار الغاز ومدى الرضا على الرئيس
وحسبه
[موسيقى]
راكب الشجاعيه
اعتبر الرئيس الامريكي
منتصف الولايه الاسبوع المقبل ستكون لحظه
سرقه في مصير الديمقراطيه في الولايات
المتحده قائلا انه يجب ان يتحدث الجميع
بصوت واحد
في امريكا
حمراء عملاقه من الجمهوريين من اجل ضمان
الفوز على الديمقراطيين في الانتخابات
النصفيه الاسبوع المقبل
اذا كنتم تريدون وقفه تدمير بلادنا وانقاذ
الحلم الامريكي يجب عليكم هذا الثلاثاء ان
تصوتوا للجمهوريين في موجه حمراء عملاقه
في اشاره الى لون
[تصفيق]
نبقى في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث
اظهرت استطلاعات عده ميلا نخبينا من اصول
اللاتينيه الى الوقوف بجانب الحزب
الجمهوري في الانتخابات النصفيه الا انهم
منقسمين حول قضايا الهجره والاقتصاد
الناخبون من الاصول اللاتينيه الجائزه
الرابحه التي يتسابق عليها الجمهوريون
والديمقراطيون لا عجب في ذلك فهم الاسرع
عموما في امريكا وكسبهم يعني كسب المزيد
من مقاعد الكونجرس فالدستور ينصوا صراحه
على اعاده توزيع المقاعد كل عشر سنوات
تبعا للتعداد السكاني بحسب تقسيم هذه
الدوائر سيطره الجمهوريون على 270 دائره
بالكونغرس بينما الديمقراطيون سيطروا فقط
على 75 دائره رقم اقل بكثير من منافسهم
عرف عن الناخبين من الاصول اللاتينيه
دعمهم الدائم للديمقراطيه الا ان
الانتخابات 2020 كشفت التوجهات جديده
اللاتينين وتوجهات اسهم بعضهم نحو
المرشحين الجمهوريين اي الرئيس ترامب رغم
جدته المعاديه للهجره وللمره الاولى في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده شارك اكثر من 32
مليون لاتيني في الانتخابات الرئاسيه اما
في عام 2022 هناك مسرح جديد لاختبار
اتجاهات اللاتينيين فالانتخابات النصفيه
ستظهر ما اذا كانت توجهات عام 2020 مستمره
ام لا عند الحديث عن الملفات الخلافيه
الانتخابات النصفيه هي الساحه التي يعبر
فيها اللاتينيون عن ارائهم باداره بيض
لملفات تمسهم كالهجره وحقوق التصويت حيث
تظهر استطلاعت راي ان معظمه اللاتينيه
يفضلون الديمقراطيين اما اقتصاديا هناك
حوالي 41% من الناخبين اللاتينيين يتفقون
مع الجمهوريين بشان الملفات الاقتصاديه في
مقابل ثلاثه واربعين بالمئه
للديمقراطيهوريس فيديو
سبونج بوب
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
قسن عنصرا عراقيه من تنظيم داعش الارهابي
الى مديريه الاستخبارات ومكافحه الارهاب
في محافظه نينوى العراقيه وفقا للمرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان فانه جرى تسلم
وعناصر داعش العراقيين عبر معبر الوليد
الحدودي مع اقليم كردستان العراق وذلك بعد
نقلهم من احد السجون اسد شمالا شرقي سوريا
اذان الاتحاد الاوروبي عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ الكوريه الشماليه واصفانيها بغير
القانونيه وداعيا للعلامه الى رد موحدا
وحازا يشمل تطبيق العقوبات الامميه واشار
مسؤول الشؤون الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى ان هذا الاطلاق يعد تصيدا
خطيرا من قبل
مطالبا الامم المتحده ومجلس الامن الدولي
بضمان التطبيق الكامل للعقوبات لمنع كوريا
الشماليه من الحصول على المواد والخبره
والتمويل لدعم برامجها التسلحيه غير
القانونيه
نفقه الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي
لانباء المتداوله حول توصلها لاتفاق حول
الحصانات القاضيه
الكامله او الجزئيه لصالح اي جهه او افراد
واكدت القوه ان لا يمكن ان تقوم باتفاقنا
يخص الحصانات القضائيه دون تشاور وقبول
مما وصفتهم باهل المصلحه كما اكدت قوى
الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي انها تضع
قضيه العداله في مقدمه القضايا التي تجب
معالجتها بصوره شامله وشفافه
وبمشاركه واسعه
حضر مواطنون في الولايات الشماليه
بالسودان من التغيرات المناخيه التي
تشهدها المنطقه فالامطار والسيول الاخيره
التي شهدتها المنطقه تسببت باضرار كبيره
وتلفا في بعض المحاصيل الاستراتيجيه في
المنطقه بالاضافه الى المخاوف المتزايده
للسكان من زياده رقعه المناطق المتضرره
مجره الزحف الصحراويه
تغيرات في المناخ وزحف صحراوي خطراني
يمثلان تهديدا وجودا لسكان الولايه
الشماليه هنا في السودان هذه الارض تعتبر
من اخصب الاراضي الزراعيه غير ان الرمال
التي فعلتها صعبه من مهمه استصلاحها
اه بدا الحديث جهرا في الولايه الشماليه
عن اتساع دائره الخطر الذي اصبح مهددا
للارض والانسان والحيوان امطار تهطل على
ارض ما تعودت عليها ورمال تتحرك بسرعه
معلنه ان لا مكان في مستقرها للدرع
والانسان
الافراد اللي بيزرعوا مزارع بتدفن يعني
التغيرات المناخيه المطر المطر مؤثر جدا
لما نيجيريا لانه نحن جاهز
اما الامطار التي شهدتها المنطقه مؤخرا
يحدثك عنها المتضررون من المزارعين الذين
قد تضرهم الامطار الى تغيير نمط الزراعي
اذا استمرت التغيرات المناخيه
مع الامطار ومع البريد الكثير حتى الصنادي
يعني البرد الشديد ده اخر النخيل ده
الرسميه تتوالى بزراعه الاحزمه الزراعيه
وزياده المساحات الخضراء ورفع الوعي
بمخاطر التغيرات المناخيه
من الولايات المتحده الصحراوي والزحف
الصحراوي طبعا بيعدي كارثه في المنطقه دي
هو مش ذات الغابات هي بتتمثل في اقامه
احذيه في المنطقه التي تتعرض لتقليل عمليه
سرعه الرياح بالتالي تثبيت القدس على
الرمليه
والعلم يتجه صوب قيمه المناخ في مدينه شرم
الشيخ المصريه يضع الجار السوداني نفسه من
الدول التي شهد التغيرا في مناخه تمظهر في
ارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده معدلاته طول
الامطار خاصه في مناطق الانتاج ما قد
يتسبب في تاثيرات على الامن الغذائي وهجره
ونزوحي ملايين الناس محمد عثمان العربيه
الشماليه
بعد اخذ ورد تراجع رئيس الحكومه لبريطاني
ياريشي سوناك عن قراره عدم المشاركه في
قمه المناخ التي تنطلق الاحد فى مصر
الاخير يرى ناشطون بيئيون ان قراره الاول
بعدم المشاركه يكشف عن عدم جديه الحكومه
في فهم التحديات البيئيه فضلا عن دور
بريطانيا الرائد في مكافحه التغيير
المناخي
لا تملك بريطانيا رفض حضور قمه تناقش احدى
اكثر الملفات انذارا بالخطر على العالم
هذا ما عبر عنه العديد من الناشطين البيئه
الذين انتقدوا تردد رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه الجديد في حضور قيمه شرم الشيخ
المناخيه قبل ان يعود للتراجع عن قراره ان
اتخاذ قرار كهذا قد يحسب سلبا على مسيرته
السياسيه
وهو ما يلقي بعض الشك على ان الحكومه تفهم
او لا تملك بالاحرى فهما واضحا بشان مدى
اهميه قضيه التغيير المناخي
تراجع اعتبرته المعارضه انه جاء تحت ضغوط
سياسيه لا على اساس قرارات قياديه وتعد
ازمه المناخ من اكثر الملفات الحاحا في
بريطانيا التي شهدت خلال الصيف موجات حر
لم يسجل مثلها في تاريخ البلاد والتي
تسببت بجفاف قد تمتد تداعته لعقود قادمه
كما ان ارتفاع درجات الحراره عن معدلها
المعتاد هذا الخريف يشير الى تسارع وتيره
الاحتباس الحراري
المملكه المتحده مثل كثير من الدول تواجه
تحديات الملحوظه بنسبه لنا بتحديد ارتفاع
درجات الحراره كما اننا سجلنا ارتفاعا في
عدد الوفيات هذا الصيف بسبب موجه الحر
وتاثيرات الامطار والفيضانات
وهو ما دفع مئات الناشطين الى الشوارع
احتجاجا على عجز الحكومه عن اتخاذ
السياسات للحد من الظواهر البيئيه ما يجعل
خلافات الحكومه تشويشا على ملفات تعد اكثر
اهميه بالنسبه للبريطانيين
بالدرام السياسيه انهم يريدون افعالا
الناس تريد من الحكومه ان تكون متماسكه
وان تنجز الاولويات التي يطالبون بها
بريطانيا الرائد في مجال مكافحه التغير
المناخي والذي شهد تحول النوعيا العام
الماضي في قمه كابتونتي 6 جعل من حضورها
في قمه هذا العام امرا ضروريا بالنسبه
للبريطانيين الذين ترى الاغلبيه منهم ان
ازمه المناخ ليست ثانويه مهما ساءت
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه التي تمر بها بريطانيا
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
في الصين اعلنت لجنه الصحه الوطنيه ان
البلاد المتمسكه بسياسه صفر كوفدنافيه
الانباء التي تتحدث عن ان الحكومه
تدرسها الصحيه
بعد مرور ثلاث سنوات على تعامل العالم مع
جائحه كورونا يعلن المسؤولون في الصين
مجددا تمسكهم بسياسه صفر كورونا رغم
تاثيرها على الحياه اليوميه واعاقتها لنمو
الاقتصادي
بكين تتمسك بسياسه صفر كوزيت الشامله رغم
زياده الاصابات المستورده من الخارج
لجنه الصحه
وردا على انتقادات داخليه وخارجيه حول
سياسه الصين في التعامل مع كورونا اكدت
انها لم تتلقى اي تعليمات بعد لتخفيض
القيود الصحيه في البلاد المفروضه منذ
وان الصين لا تزال تسجل اصابات جديده
بكرونا بلغت اكثر من ثلاثه الاف و600 حاله
كما رصدت الفرق الصحيه بورا جديده للوباء
شمال شرقي البلاد قرب الحدود مع روسيا
وكوريا الشماليه
وفرضت الحكومه تدابير اغلاق لمده اسبوع
على 600,000 شخص يعيشون قرب مصنع لهواتف
ايفون بعد فراري موظفين منه لتفادي الحجر
الصحي
ويرى خبراء في الصحه الدوليه ان الصين
ربما ستبقي على القيود الصحيه لعام اخر
وتواصل الاختبارات الصحيه وسط مخاوف من
تفشي فيروسات خارجيه خاصه ان الانباء
تتحدث عن انتشار ثلاثه فيروسات في
الولايات المتحده وكذلك الحال في دول
اوروبيه بينها فرنسا التي تشهد تفشيا
واسعا لالتهاب القصبات الهوائيه جاسم محسن
العربيه